ce jeudi pour ce virus le nouveau robot
de la nasa doit se poser à la surface de
mars
sa mission explorer un cratère à la
recherche d'un indice de vie passée un
géologue de l'université de l'alberta
joue un rôle clé dans cette mission
choisir les échantillons les plus
prometteurs qui seront rapportées sur
terre
pendant des années il va explorer la
surface de mars
c'est la première fois que la nasa
cherche des preuves directes de vie
ancienne se remémore le terrain de jeu
du rover persévérance c'est un cratère
autrefois rempli d'eau mais la grande
nouveauté c'est qu'il ne fera pas
observé les roches
on veut aussi ramener des échantillons
et c'est mon rôle dans cette mission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
krycer est un spécialiste des météorites
en particulier celles qui proviennent de
mars et qu'on a retrouvé sur terre les
météorites sont les seul échantillon de
la planète rouge qu'on a ici et qu'on
peu étudié en laboratoire
météorites sont formidables c'est ce qui
a orienté mes recherches vers mars
elle nous renseigne sur sa composition
une partie de son histoire et même sur
sa formation
mais c'est un échantillon un peu biaisée
pour avoir une météorite il faut que
mars soit frappé par un astéroïde qui
arrachent des morceaux de la surface et
les envois vers nous c'est très violent
et seuls les roches les plus jeunes et
les plus solides survivent à tout le
processus
malheureusement ce sont les roches les
plus fragiles et les plus anciennes qui
contiennent les secrets les mieux gardés
de mars
pourquoi les conditions propices à la
vie sont elles disparu et bien sûr y at
il déjà eu de la vie en quelques jours
un second va pénétrer dans la main sa
place faire de mars
à coups de bouclier thermique de
parachute
et de rétrofusées
le rover va ralentir et s'approcher de
sa cible
puis un treuil le déposera doucement ça
du moins on l'espère
on les surnomme les sept minutes de
terreur parce que tout se passe de façon
automatique
il n'y a personne sur terre que
télécommande la sonde à cause des délais
de communication avec marché
c'est là que va commencer le vrai
travail de chris rudge
géologue à l'université de l'alberta il
a été choisi comme un des deux
scientifiques responsables des
échantillons a rapporté et ce n'est pas
le choix qui manque
le cratère jay 0 est un ancien lac qui
s'est asséchée depuis aujourd'hui on
reconnaît encore le tracé de la rivière
qui a déposé des sédiments pour former
ce delta
il y a donc toute une variété d'roches
accessibles aux chercheurs jazz ou les
planteurs jazz euros a été choisi parce
que les roches qu'on y retrouve compte
entre 3 5 et 4 milliards d'années
c'est une période critique dans
l'histoire de mars
on est passé d'un endroit tempéré avec
une atmosphère et de l'eau liquide à la
surface à la planète désertique est
couverte de rouille qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
oui si on ne comprend pas encore
pourquoi il y a eu un tel changement
à cette période précise
[Musique]
l'autre grande question c'est la
présence de vie sur terre à la même
époque des colonies de bactéries ont
donné aux roches des formes bien
particulière l'équipe scientifique de
preures stephens s'est rendu en
australie pour mieux comprendre les
défis que le rover devra surmonter
il est équipé en conséquence sur mars
ces instruments scientifiques et ses
caméras vont aider les chercheurs à
identifier les roches les plus
prometteuses mais c'est sur terre qu'on
pourra vraiment dire si elles
contiennent des traces de vie ici on a
accès à des instruments infiniment plus
puissant pour percer les moindres
secrets qui se cachent au coeur des
échantillons les indices de vie je
prendre différentes formes
les roches peuvent avoir cette structure
en feuillets où un carrément contenir
des bactéries fossilisées lui il y à
aussi différentes signatures chimiques
qui trahissent la présence d'une forme
de vie ancienne
c'est le genre de choses qu'on doit
valider en laboratoire sur terre
il y à un parallèle à faire avec les
roches lunaires choisi par les
astronautes des missions apollo
c'est de loin la plus grande collection
de matériel extra terreste rapporter sur
terre
aujourd'hui ces roches sont étudiés par
des chercheurs qui n'étaient même pas
nés à l'époque pour répondre à des
questions qu'on ne se posait pas encore
la mission persévérance vise à créer
même genre de collection mais pour mars
ça va donner lieu à des conversations
intéressantes pour décider si on
échantillons ou non les différents
endroits qu'on visite on a une idée
générale de ce qu'on veut mais tout va
dépendre de ce qu'on va découvrir sur le
terrain à une année martienne soit deux
années terrestres pour explorer le
cratère avant de s'aventurer à
l'extérieur c'est là que sont les roches
qui intéresse le plus cru surn des
roches volcaniques beaucoup plus
ancienne que celle qu'on retrouve dans
les météorites en déterminant l'âge
exact de ces roches
on aura une meilleure idée du moment où
les différents événements ont eu lieu
pour l'instant on n'a pas une très bonne
chronologie de ce qui s'est passé dans
l'histoire de mars
oui dans la queue lundi l'idéal serait
d'avoir au moins trente échantillons
tellement diversifiée intéressant qu'on
n'aura pas le choix d'aller chercher
plus anciens pour ce conte
car il faudra ensuite une deuxième
mission pour récupérer les échantillons
aient quitté mars et troisième pour
rattraper la capsule en orbite est faire
le trajet de retour livraison en 2031
si tout va bien
mais dix ans d'attentes c'est très peu
pour quelqu'un qui rêve depuis toujours
d'avoir un bout de mars qu'il a lui-même
choisi
j'en rêve depuis que j'ai 13 ans j'avais
même dit mot pour mot je veux être là
quand on va rapporter des échantillons
de mars
pour moi ce serait le rêve d'une vie qui
se réalise comme tu veux
[Musique]